el 18 de enero de 2015 murió Alberto
nisman el fiscal argentino que había
denunciado un presunto encubrimiento del
gobierno de Cristina Fernández a los
autores del atentado a la asociación
mutual israelita Argentina de 1994 el
acto terrorista más grande de la
historia del país sudamericano al día
siguiente nisman debía revalidar sus
acusaciones pero fue encontrado muerto
con un disparo en la cabeza en el baño
de su departamento en el barrio Porteño
de Puerto Madero
una escena poco clara que profundizó
irreversiblemente la grieta política
Argentina y dio lugar a versiones
cruzadas de un lado refieren a un
subsidio y del otro a un asesinato
Yo espero que se esclarezca que que
vayan presas los culpables quedaron dos
hijas sin padre y además para el país
entero es un y el mundo entero es un mal
ejemplo que un fiscal de la nación este
muerto por y que no haya ningún
esclarecimiento Cuál es la idea entonces
la primera demostrar a partir
No ya de los planteos jurídicos que
vamos a hacer posteriormente
sino de la más simple lógica del
disparate
judicial
institucional y político que es esta
acusación actualmente el expediente
sobre su fallecimiento está estancado a
cargo del fiscal Eduardo tallano y el
juez Julián alcolini ambos afines a la
derecha nacional no se ha podido
comprobar que se trate un intento de
asesinato tal como insistió la esposa de
nisman la jueza Sandra Arroyo Salgado
Por ahora sólo están procesados Diego
lagomarcino asesor informático y dueño
del arma implicada y los cuatro
custodios encargados de la seguridad del
fiscal